[Aplausos]
[Música]
m
mas para mim é sempre o mesmo
era normal crescer muito impressionado
a verdade em braille está ligada a
falta de prática pessoal
e eu
[Música]
são os propósitos
dois
s
de originalidade seriamente ideia de fazer
as últimas previsões de ideias são
destruído é que ele só comprou
positividade definir
aqui temos que viver e vitalidade para
atingir os objetivos da agência
superar sua difícil situação e
paciência para não ver os problemas
[Música]
S
os 5 da cidade
a discussão com o cristal
de família
Ações
sim
logo após toda contenção de comportamento
ou seja, de um campus eu quero procurar um
milagre social
[Aplausos]
isso será possível
S
[Música]
26º lugar para este
proposta
um segundo para muitas dificuldades
e as dificuldades
[Música]
a essas dificuldades são períodos com
grupos superam as dificuldades
e muita gente
é uma terra
[Música]
esses são os mais sociais
aproveitar
assim
[Música]
S
e importante da eficácia nestes
spas próprios
[Música]
entre ser completamente
eu
sim
Eu não sei como será sua mente, nós vamos
lançamento
impacto
[Música]
ou sim
e assim é
sim
d
se fosse internet
eu
[Música]
ao aplicar as mídias sociais
Oh
através de uma saída de ajuda
[Música]
pareceu
de todos
p
agora
e 140 pesos
S
simplesmente
como um protocolo
primeiro
nesse ponto procure alianças executadas sem
soluções de disputas
responda gratuitamente quando
açao
efetivamente
[Música]
reparos
eu me pergunto até então
[Música]
daquele livro
procurando mais
público
[Aplausos]